le temps passe et les choses ne changent
pas le monde de la finance est
impitoyable l'appât du gain toujours
plus grand malgré la révélation de
plusieurs scandales l'expliquent en 2014
puis il est pas damas peppers deux ans
plus tard l'évasion fiscale se
poursuivent pour la majorité des banques
européennes
chaque année ce sont quelque 20
milliards d'euros soit 14% de leurs
bénéfices totaux qui sont enregistrés
dans 17 territoires à la fiscalité
particulièrement favorable plus
communément appelée paradis fiscaux
malgré l'importance croissante de ces
questions dans le débat public et dans
le monde politique les banques
européennes n'ont pas réduit de manière
significative le recours aux paradis
fiscaux l'observatoire a réalisé cette
étude entre 2014 et 2020 les 17 pays
considérés comme des paradis fiscaux
elles doivent combiner deux éléments un
taux d'imposition effectif inférieur ou
égal à 15 % mais aussi une productivité
des banques par employé particulièrement
élevé en tête de ces territoires le
royaume uni et ses îles vierges mais pas
de tout soupçon les bénéfices
comptabilisés par les banques dans les
paradis fiscaux sont anormalement élevé
280 3000 euros par salarié contre
environ 65000 euros dans les pays qui ne
sont pas des paradis fiscaux de quoi
suggérer que les bénéfices comptabilisés
dans les paradis fiscaux viennent
principalement d'autres pays là où les
services sont produits la conséquence
directe est évidemment pour les états
sur les 36 établissements passés au
peigne fin l'observatoire estime qu'un
taux minimum de 15 % permettrait de
générer 3 à 5 milliards d'euros de
recettes supplémentaires pour les pays
européens avec un taux de 25% ces
chiffres triplerait pour atteindre 10 à
13 milliards d'euros des chiffres qui
forcément remettre la question de la
justice fiscale sur la table en ligne de
mire la multinationale des discussions
sont en cours au sein de l'organisation
de coopération et de développement
économiques pour une imposition minimum
de 15% justement des profits à de ces
mastodontes pour lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux mais pour nombre
d'économistes ce n'est clairement pas
suffisant les dirigeants qui font de la
fraude fiscale délibéré doivent aller en
prison mais si les banques et les
avocats qui les aides doivent aussi
faire de la prison je pense que ça sera
que par ça j'en ai discuté par un ami
avocat avec un ami avocat fiscaliste me
dire que cette méthode qui permettra de
faire respecter les règles mais il faut
voir aussi une autre chose cette
concurrence fiscale partout sur la
planète est liée à la mondialisation et
on n'y arrivera pas dans la
mondialisation il faut démondialiser il
faut revenir avec des règles nationales
à des états qui ont les règles qui
peuvent fixer les règles de justice et
les règles fiscales qu'ils veulent et
les faire appliquer c'est comme ça par
cette démondialisation qu'on reviendra à
plus de justice fiscale pour moi mettre
tout le monde en prison c'est plutôt
utopiste surtout lorsqu'on regarde de
plus près qui se trouverait en ligne de
mire quelles banques usent le plus de
ces procédés eh bien on trouve en tête
de liste la britannique hsbc plus de 62%
de ses bénéfices avant impôts ont été
comptabilisés dans des paradis fiscaux
entre 2018 et 2020 elle est talonnée par
l'italienne monte des patxi donc quasi
50% des bénéfices ont la même destinée
en france c'est la société générale qui
est en pôle position avec 13,8 pour cent
de ses profits placés dans les paradis
fiscaux devant le crédit agricole et bnp
paribas l'évasion fiscale un embarras
pour les états qui ne date pas d'hier en
2017 les ong oxfam dénonce et déjà ces
pratiques quatre ans plus tard le bilan
est sans équivoque aucune amélioration
notable au delà des beaux discours il va
falloir davantage de volonté aux états
pour enfin sortir de l'enfer des paradis
fiscaux mais l'enfer justement est-il
pas pavé de bonnes intentions